first of all let me start by saying this
movie is fantastic I just told night
this is one of his best films uh you
both are so good in it I'm sure you're
hearing this from everyone and I'm done
I'm out no but so I'm going to read this
because I have an individual question
for you and I want to make sure I say it
right okay uh do more people want to
talk to you about mind Hunter Frozen
Hamilton or your one episode of and just
like that
it's funny and just like that it gets a
lot of play uh with people but I would
say mindhunter is the most is the most
asked about thing for sure that is the
right answer okay I didn't know there
was a right or wrong yeah there is
because I could continue talking have
you seen mine hunter I haven't okay
listen sir wait what you know that
foreign
okay it is it is probably the best thing
Netflix has ever made
um it's really incredible and you know
this it's incredible television it's
like I I can't emphasize enough how much
it's worth your time I have been told
that many many times I will I'll still
refuse to watch if you watch BBC's like
rice to candleford
exactly
actually I keep saying I want to watch
things you're ready you told me not oh
you don't need to but yeah I will watch
it we'll see remind in a year please
text him and be like have you watched or
in six months in a year oh a year
um
so I do want to talk about something
actually serious um you guys are
obviously openly gay you're playing a
gay couple in a movie this big you know
a big Hollywood movie which honestly I
don't think this this thing could have
happened 10 15 years ago I think that
it's it's amazing that um and it's not
like the focus of the story it just
happens to be so can you sort of talk
about that and how cool it is and how
you know just if you talk a little bit
about that I can't I came out like 15
years ago so I and I remember when I
came out it was 2009 so whatever that
math is 14 years ago
um
I remember thinking like okay I'm sort
of
putting aside any dreams of being in a
big Hollywood movie because it didn't
seem like that would be possible
uh gay marriage wasn't even legal yet
and so the fact that we're in and grew
up watching Knights movies of course so
now we're in a night movie where a
married gay couple is the central family
of the story and sort of the love story
of the movie and and in some ways with
Chris and our daughter the heart of the
movie uh and we're two out actors and
it's like Whiplash of how fast that
happened and I just feel I know we both
feel insanely insanely lucky to be the
age we are now in the time we are now
riding this wave of progress It's
extraordinary is there anything you
wanted to add I mean I think that's a
very good answer and I hardly agree with
all of it but yeah I
yeah I I feel very uh grateful very
proud to be in this film and I think the
way it does handle the that their
relationship and
um the
the queer narrative that they have lived
is it's done very sensitively and it's
done very deftly by night it's uh it
honors I think a narrative that a lot of
queer people will be able to relate to
without it becoming the Crux of the film
and at the same time I think that them
being a loving family is universal and I
think that the film really exemplifies
that it's a really um it really
demonstrates that kind of the thing that
our community speak of a lot is Love Is
Love and this film totally shows that I
think what do you think it is about end
of the world movies and television shows
that we just love that genre and keep
coming back to it
I think because we well right now I
guess we've survived as a pandemic we've
got the uh we've got the climate crisis
being a very present uh Fear Factor in
our lives and I think you know night is
purposefully playing on those fears I
think the fears that we have as a kind
of our Collective
our Collective fears as a as a society
and um I I like I remember I was
obsessed with the apocalypse and and
Deep Impact and Armageddon did that for
me yeah and and like I was so obsessed
that I looked into the Nostradamus
prophecies I read the book of Revelation
twice in the bath
um and I thought I was gonna kind of
crack the code of what 666 was
and what the what the who the four
horsemen the apocalypse were and I feel
like
I feel like for as long as
our time has been documented there we've
always felt like it's around the corner
you know our our the ending of of this
is our of our own lives as our only
certainty so why wouldn't we think about
it all ending and um I think I think
that really does hook you into the the
film
couldn't say it better
so one of the things
um there is some moments where there is
uh like 10 pages of dialogue that you
guys are filming long where the camera
is going around I love the way he shoots
this and some of the use of close-ups
but what was it like working with Knight
and what surprised you about working
with him on set in the way he directs
and the way he moves camera first of all
I didn't know that it was going to be
shot mostly in chronological order which
was really amazing acting wise to start
it's rarely you get that opportunity to
start at the beginning basically and go
to the end
um he told us when we were we had two
weeks of rehearsal which is also very
rare in a movie and great and we learned
a lot about our characters and each
other during that time and he told us
you know I have the entire movie boarded
turn around and you will see in there
were the cartoons of not only like like
this the ideas of the shots but the
close-ups that you're talking about and
the camera movements that you're talking
about all pre-planned so when we would
show up on set we wouldn't do a
rehearsal that's what those first two
weeks were for reading and talking and
discussing lines when you finally show
up on set and you start shooting the
cameras are in their position he tells
you where to stand tells you where to
sit and tells you exactly what he wants
so the challenge is humanizing and and
um connecting given the very specific uh
blocking and movements and words and
this Collective Group of Seven actors
including Kristen the extraordinary
eight-year-olds who was her first movie
and she's been given this sort of like
Precision acting exercise uh we all
really
we all really believed in the movie and
we all really believed in each other and
we just went full out every time no
matter if the camera was on you or not
and it created this real
like support and Ensemble vibe to the
movie we all had each other's backs and
night was he would get really excited
and really enthusiastic and uh there was
a real sort of Team energy on the set
which was exciting
is it weird because the thing is I would
imagine with another director who
doesn't have Knight's track record it's
hard to do something like that to really
believe in this Lim like this window
that he's trying to shoot in but when
it's someone like Knight is it sort of
easier to give yourself over to a
process that doesn't allow for a lot of
improvisation
yeah I I personally that took me a while
to get used to I've been on a film
before where it was really
improvisational it was really workshoppy
it was a super collaborative just like
very different directors and they and I
so enjoyed both processes but it took a
while to what you're there to do as an
actor with night is you're there to to
Aid him realize his vision he's kind of
like if if if the set if the dialogue if
all of the prop details are all these
different palettes that he's painting
with you are also as an actor and
another layer of that that he's kind of
molding and shaping and he's this like
ultimate Puppet Master in a way of
what's going on and you're you the best
thing to do is to yield to what he wants
in a way and and that can take a little
bit of is this interesting thing of like
still thinking but kind of
slightly switching off and just trusting
him and going okay he's made these
Incredible movies
he knows what he's doing there is an
element of a leap of faith about it
because you actually have the it's the
least control I've ever had over
anything I've performed
um but at the same time the script was
kind of like oh just like overtaking me
as well so it was it was a really um
yeah such an interesting process to be
part of I know a lot of actors and they
can't watch themselves on screen I don't
know how the two of you are but I am
curious what it was like watching this
for the first time because it is you're
doing you know what I mean like it's
such an interesting uh the choices M
night is going for anyway I'm just
curious what it was like uh for both of
you
it was cool I I was I was reminded of
how intense we got I I was like wow we
were all seven of us were really going
for it um and it it felt uh it took me
back to that feeling of being in the
cabin which is a very specific
experience as a group of actors to like
go to such a dark intense Place
collectively as a group uh and we did
that every time between action and cut
and so watching it sort of sense memory
sent me back there I've there are
moments when I I started to feel like I
was gonna cry uh because I remembered so
viscerally the feeling of being there
and the overwhelming emotion that would
would happen
um and I thought I just I thought wow
night really made something I thought it
was beautiful I thought he did a really
beautiful job yeah same way I realized
that my body was twitching whilst I was
watching it which is actually what
night's body does if you watched with
the monitor he's experiencing what the
actors are experiencing and but I was
sat in the theater being like Oh okay
yep I'm doing all the things that I was
doing in the when I was sat there
strapped to the chair but uh I found it
really thrilling I I think it's a kind
of dream come true moment he he makes
movies and like I guess to quote Harry
Styles he makes movie movies
um and uh I've never like seen my eyes
in like a tight close-up like that on a
huge screen or anything like he just he
just fits these things to this this
thing together in in a way that I've
never like seen myself in such a kind of
like big production
wow this is super cool on that note I
will just say thank you so much thank
you so much so great to see you